take the wheel
just take the wheel
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by queen latifah
she's a grammy and emmy award-winning
oscar-nominated multi-hyphenate pop
culture icon who's been entertaining
audiences for over 30 years and you can
catch her starting alongside adam
sandler in her latest film hustle which
is set to release on netflix june 8th
queen latifah welcome to the show thank
you for having me how are you around
spicy food before we dig in here i'm
good around spicy food i enjoy the smell
the aroma
the hopefully taste
[Music]
all right so just take a bite and just
take a bite oh that feels good
nice
cool
classic is silly not bad at all
smokey
so i want to come out the gate by
complimenting you on your performance in
hustle which is a movie that i really
enjoyed not only for the story but also
because it's a very athletic film and
really nails the sport of basketball in
a way that's not always a given in
hollywood and you've described working
with adam sandler as being a live stream
what draws you to his work so i think
you both have a really good compass when
it comes to blending humor with themes
of family and sentimentality
i quite agree with you i couldn't agree
more um i think he's just had an amazing
career and he's a cool person i've known
him through the years and he's just
always been the same cool guy all the
every time i see him
but i'm definitely a fan of his and i
think he as an actor takes chances you
know he takes risks and he pushes the
limit and when he dives into it he dives
in 100
and people like really respect and love
him for it i sure do so you know playing
his wife in this movie was a pleasure
[Music]
pineapple cayenne i was like that's kind
of sweet yeah a little uh island vibe
over here
that's a good vibe right there there we
go yeah
so i'm really interested in the hip-hop
scene that you came up in in the late
1980s and in particular this quote from
your longtime creative partner shakeem
compare who once told the new york times
we would play madison square garden and
then do a rodeo which hello
snap
which la roller rink turned music venue
do you remember more fondly skate land
or world on wheels um
well
both of the shows rocked
but ended in some
craziness so
you know it was really heavy gang
banging at that time um
i think i was with ice tea on that show
i remember having to hide in the office
of the manager and it was like a gate
pulled down and you could just see it
being banged in from the outside like
what the f is going on
this is crazy i love hip-hop um
and then the other one i remember
putting my mic down at the skate land
and letting them give a shout out and
then the guy he grabbed the bike and was
like i want to shout out this dude he
started throwing up all his sides and i
couldn't get the mic back i was like
damn what did i do and i'm like yeah
yeah
i finally got the mic back
that ended up in a fight in there too
but it was so much fun back then you
know what i mean it was a little
dangerous but it was so much fun and the
music was just like it was fresh and new
and i was part of that era and that
coming up of a new sound in hip-hop so
it was cool with me
i don't remember ever really skating in
those places
just hanging
well speaking of skating are you ready
to skate on over to the next wing
slide
ah okay let me get what we got what we
got
this is the mezzclean here in the third
spot oh shoot
now
i hope it makes me laugh like the old
days
[Music]
we're getting in the zone a little bit
yeah that's doable no this is a
beautiful this is not this only a third
one i know
but i'm building i'm building over here
you know i know
you got some really good questions to
distract me with so thank you
thank you for doing a little homework
there
so vocal ranger john clayton once said
of you in jazz times technically she can
pretty much do anything she needs to
with her voice and since she's an
actress she knows how to sell the lyric
is there at all a connection for you
between the way that you approach a song
and the way that you approach a role
um i was thinking
absolutely
i'll start with that just to get me
there music
goes with me everywhere i go so no
matter what i do there's always music
involved and
i think when i was a less experienced
actor younger actor
i had to really think of
maybe real life experiences to really
get me where i needed to be with where
the character was
but i really don't have to do that
anymore and music is so close i can play
a song and get exactly where i need to
be as long as that song it touches me in
a certain way i can just throw it on it
puts me right where i need to be
emotionally
and then i can go do that scene however
many times
off the top of your head without
thinking about it too much the all-time
greatest jazz standard
whoo
i mean it's not really jazz standard but
strange fruit is
some powerful song there we go wow why
would this make me go to strange fruit
damn
this is some wild [ __ ] i don't know
um i'll think of something more uh happy
a little later maybe
maybe maybe maybe are you ready to move
on here to the next wig you're doing
great
this is the los calientes verde here in
the four spot
okay let's see what we got can we even
see see any more clearly
oh yeah it starts to hit a little back
there yeah it's happening
so two of your life details that i find
interesting is that you worked at the
wiz before you were famous and then also
owned a video rental store in jersey
city which are both total anachronisms
do you at all miss the days of cds and
vhs tapes and what do you think that
we've lost in this age of ubiquitous
streaming
i mean i miss
seeing credits being able to open up
something and just read the credits and
always be able to just grab it and look
and know who produced what you know
instead of having to go look it up you
know i like i like all that kind of
stuff i think it's fun to kind of have
like a little library
i do feel like today's audience feels
that independence that we felt back then
in the 80s because for a minute it was
like label label label but then the
digital era allowed everybody to become
an artist and everybody become their own
label
but you still have to get out there and
get known so
you know you were able to kind of create
your own lane and a lot of people who
probably wouldn't have got gotten a look
are now super successful
and some people really
need to not be there but
but i think a lot of people really
should be there who might not have
gotten an opportunity if it had stayed
the same
oh yeah let's do it
you know that reaper part
carolina repod sauce
that's nice
i think you undersold i think you
undersold over here i'm actually
surprised i must tell you
i'm i i noticed like a little setup over
here someone one of these is the
knockout but so far i'm still on your
feet i'm still on your feet you know
when we dodge and he's pretty good
all right queen latifah every current
segment on our show called explain that
gram where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
put the picture up over here on the
monitor you just tell us the bigger
story
oh my god oh man we were backstage
somewhere huh me and tupac were pretty
much label mates um i was talking to
tommy boy records
digital underground was signed to tommy
boy records
initially i took treach on the road as
my roadie tretchy went on to become the
nature naughty by nature
um and tupac was pretty much a roadie
with digital
and he became a rapper in the group and
made up the humpty dance and they made
the song the humpty dance of which
tupac created the dance to and it became
a smash hit
we toured together so we went all across
the country
san francisco doing a show my first show
over ten thousand dollars like which was
a new year's eve show
um at this cool gay club in san
francisco i was like yo i'm here he's
like yo i'ma hook up with you so tupac
came to the club with me and i was like
yo come with two pockets in the building
they went crazy in there i was like
they're gonna tell you about your
clothes come here he's like man he took
his shirt off anyway we had so much fun
you know but that was like my brother
and he would like he's the type of
person i would like if he loved you if
he was cool with you he lays life down
for you so i miss him and i love him
good times love that all right up next
and we're probably hi
anyway
how would you describe rock and jock to
a kid born in the 2000s yo that was fun
and rock and jack needs to come back and
try to say it like somebody really needs
to get the
get it back you know in a really fun way
so rock and jock was just a chance for
you know everybody to get together
and
play sports all your favorite
celebrities from tom cruise to me you
know and whether it was a basketball
game or in this case softball with a
young john stewart by the way right
there look at john's door oh my god
i just remember playing one of the rock
and jock b-ball jams and i did a theme
song for it i think as a matter of fact
i remember tom cruise playing and that
dude was he was not a very good
basketball player but he was dogged with
defense
nobody he was hounding like all these
people who thought they could ball
as soon as he started guarding them he
would not relent he was on their asses
and he i was like yo this dude is no
joke he was just so fit and going so
hard i mean i was like yo tom cruise is
dope
he was on him
all right are you ready to move on here
to the back half we can't be stopped
cannot be stopped i hope
so this is the housing ghost collards
and ghost over here well
from hot and saucy i'm looking at this
hairstyle on this
we gonna see what it do okay
kind of cute
that's got a little surprising sweetness
to it too
there it is
i had to wait for it
there you go
here we go
if it wasn't gonna give me that then i
was gonna have to give it a thumbs down
i'm feeling it i'm feeling that that's
that tingle there we go
yeah i'm feeling it i'm feeling the
tingle
so i'll forever have a soft place in my
heart for living single growing up i
remember really looking forward to that
fox thursday night lineup and i remember
my dad used to let me stay up an hour
past my bedtime even so i could watch
new york undercover afterwards of course
wow
that's what's up
i love that you remember that i actually
i have a very profound uh living single
memory if you'd like to hear it i'm with
it i became a man watching living single
i'm like i'm looking into your eyes and
i see change yeah yeah well this is
where this is where it shifted this is
where i shifted just
like a portal like i'm looking there and
feeling what tell me what happened so
there was an episode where overton was
having these sort of like fever dream
fantasies that featured cameos from tlc
and i remember when i saw that on tv
like my whole insides just melted oh my
god and then i remember going up to my
dad the next day and i asked him you
know because i knew i was too young but
i was like dad is it possible for like a
girl my age to grow up and when i'm an
adult look exactly like an adult now and
he looked at me and he goes uh
not exactly but pretty similar you know
and i remember that because i was a
little let down by it oh no i was
looking for my left eye you know oh
[Music]
whoever was hot at that time they were
on our show you weren't the only one who
became a man watching that show
what we were doing then no one else was
doing you know but it was still coming
from a relatable point of view and i
think that's what made it
successful is that you you could relate
to these characters you know in some way
shape or form one or the other and or
some of these stories in one way or the
other or just laugh at the comedy of it
all or the ridiculousness of it and we
had some great actors on that show you
know we did our thing
oh man yo
this has like four out of five
ready born ready all right okay
is
am
i
i'm going mm-hmm
oh boy mm-hmm mm-hmm see that from the
front
mm-hmm right away and then you gotta
turn it from the mat remember i'm gonna
run
[Music]
this would be good in some ramen
i might put that in my noodles
in get those things spicy
see you are a hot sauce person when you
walked in you you shied away from it a
little bit but i think it was an
undersell i think was an undersell over
delivery situation over here i'm sorry
i've seen people cry on this show
profusely so
so you came in humbly i did yeah you
know i didn't want to talk a big game
and then crumble you know so i came in
humble
and even humble
as my aunt angel would say is it true
that the scene and set it off and your
character cleo crashes through the bank
in a suburban is it true that that scene
had to be done in one take because it
required shutting down wilshire
boulevard
i believe you are right they had to get
that right
there was a lot of that on that movie
gary needed things like i need another
helicopter i want to blow this up you
know what i mean it wasn't just like
some little things gary was asking for i
need you to shut this whole thing
straight up we need to
you know and and i appreciated that you
know that level of of excellence that he
wanted
and if you see his videos all the videos
he did with cube was what made me want
to do
a video with him from the beginning it
was just how cinematic his videos were
and what stories they told and how
beautifully shot they were
but gary and i were both looking to take
it up a notch and so that was the film
that we were able to you know really
show our chops as actor slash director
you know and um
yeah life's never been the same since
that movie
honestly
okay quinn latifah
this next one
is the bomb beyond insanity
oh my god okay
i'm still tingling by the way from
turfing's curse
all right i'm trying not to let my nose
run
what's matter with jesus he's all right
man what do you do
whoa
i'm just saying
that yep me too
i'm
[Music]
relax your chi
your cheese too
jesus
take the will
so i know that you've long rep jersey
not the least of which when it comes to
your comfort food proclivities
for the uninitiated what's an italian
style hot dog and what makes the ones
that jimmy buff so special
i wonder
who this is this makes you speak
differently
okay
um how will survive
hey yeah
you know what i don't you know this this
is good this would be good for festivals
um
the kids don't need to do anything
drug-related you need the bomb
you get your life it will open you up in
ways
you know what i mean i think that's a
great idea don't need to go on a walk
about just do that
and you will find your spirit
my god
um jimmy buffs sausage
inside of
now you cut a piece of a roll you split
the thing open you put two hot dogs in
there you put some
like diced up potatoes with peppers and
onions you just push that mush that up
in there put that with your mustard or
your ketchup or whatever you want
and that's it right there and that roll
is so soft you know it's not like a full
big roll it like just kind of opens in
the middle like a pita you know what i
mean like
and that
jimmy buffs brings me back
to where i need to be
home
and just in time
now that i know who i am
i wasn't sure about who i was
and now that i
know i belong
to the universe
i can't be tethered to this earth
there are other planets to see
strange new worlds
i should be boldly going
i don't know where
where no one's gone before that's a good
place i was thinking i could go there
i just didn't want to really say it i
didn't want to seem weird
you
yeah i think i need one of these yeah
this is nice this make your lash come
off
yeah that'll make you spin in your bar
chair right there
oh
oh my gosh i have to continue okay
all right here we go here we go
the questions are so good it's good
man that's the coldest hot sauce ever
there we go
did it go into my eye
what the hell
what is happening
so i was listening to an acting career
advice podcast we talked about how
sometimes you'll spend almost your whole
paycheck from a project on the tools to
help you nail that project like extra
rehearsal time coaches etc where does
that impulse come from because it sounds
like very solid advice i'm just not sure
i've ever heard it before
yeah
i needed that to come out there we go um
wow
i know who you disrespectful
you shouldn't speak to people like that
honestly my desire to do a great job
implores me to do what i can to make
sure that i do or i know this is a live
show and this has just not enough
rehearsal and i want to rock this thing
so i want to go in and do more you know
what i mean i know i need a few more
rehearsals i'll pay for it myself but
i'm gonna i'm gonna make sure that i'm
not gonna fall flat on my face cause
i know when i happen to when i don't
the bomb could could make you hit the
ground you know not you though
not you though no i'm not going down
not as long as
that got my lord
by my side
i might preach on this show
i might give you a word or two
i didn't even know i was gonna play that
role in life but i might have a gospel
show in my life amen amen to that
you don't have to if you don't want to
you might as well put the monkey in it
there we go if we come this far come on
that's a big dab but this is a good spot
so the last dab
we ending at the apollo and
we once began
ah cheers cheers what a run oh boy
[Music]
here we go again there we go
but the good news is that we've hit the
final bell and we're still on our feet
if we've learned anything along the way
it's that you're somebody who can do a
little bit of everything from being a
musician an author an actor a producer
but most of all a dreamer and i know
that one of those dreams is to direct or
star in a sci-fi film maybe a seed that
was planted when you grew up watching
star trek so under these distressing
conditions
can you describe to me the vision of a
queen latifah sci-fi film
i'm alone on a planet
and then i'm not alone
and then i am alone
and then colors happen
and then [ __ ] goes down
and all is bad and then i save myself
and then someone saves me and i save
them
and then we transport to somewhere else
and then the real director comes in and
writes us a good script we throw that
out
that was a terrible idea
then we get get spielberg on the line
and we get spielberg
and then it becomes
a real movie we get george lucas
involved
and then um and then we make something
really dope
well that sounds like an automatic green
light and look at you queen latifah
taking on the wings of death and living
to tell the tale and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
[Music]
what do i have going on in my life i got
a movie coming out with adam sandler
called hustle
it's gonna be crazy i also have a movie
coming out called end of the road also
on netflix i got a show called the
equalizer my equalizer
but today i might have met my match a
little bit
but i live to tell the tale
ql
in the building we have survived
i survived hot once
[Music]
the bomb
that's the one was it everything you
were expecting it to be
you were
more than i expected it to be
did you have a good time this was
amazing
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and i have an announcement to make the
first ever hot sauce for kids hot wins
junior it just got a little bit hotter
you know the green say hello to our
brand new hot sauce the yellow
a super mild hot sauce with sweet
tropical heat from mango pineapple and
scotch bonnet pepper the yellow it's
ready to party with tacos nuggies heck
even ice cream to get your hands on the
newest hot ones junior sauce visit
heatness.com
to pick up the yellow